et en france à partir de ce matin les
règles changent en ce qui concerne le
pass vaccinale le délai entre chaque
dose est raccourcie à quatre mois des
millions de personnes sont susceptibles
5 millions presque deux français sont
susceptibles de perdre leur pass vaccine
allons voir tout de suite on va
retrouver tout de suite notre reporter
katia pique nique devant le ministère de
la santé
[Musique]
oms jours à katia qu'est ce qui change à
partir d'aujourd'hui
oui bah comme vous le disiez il ya une
nouvelle date d'expiration pour le pas
ce n'est plus sept mois mais quatre mois
pour ceux qui n'ont pas fait la
troisième dose et ça devient une
acrobatie pour des millions de français
alors le post vaccinale dans quatre mois
au lieu de 7 s'il n'y a pas eu de 12,2
rappel de contamination récente c'est à
dire je m'explique le rappel doit être
fait au plus tard à quatre mois après la
deuxième injection pour les doublements
vacciner au plus tard quatre mois après
la première injection pour ceux qui ont
eu le coc vit depuis une dose de vaccin
et même des lèvres au plus tard quatre
mois après l'infection pour ceux qui ont
une dose ont été contaminées par le
virus environ 4 millions de français
seront est concerné selon le ministère
de la santé alors comment at on fait le
calcul est bien parce qu'en fait 9
millions de personnes sont dans le cas
qui a fait la première dose ou le rappel
depuis plus de quatre mois mais entre
temps évidemment avec la flambée omicron
et bien la moitié d'entre eux ont été
contaminés c'est à dire 4 4 millions 5,5
millions et pour eux le pass reste
valide un pour ceux qui ont été
contaminés à noter cela ne concerne pas
les adolescents qui gardent leurs passes
sanitaires ou vaccinale selon leur âge
sept mois la dose de rappel pour eux
n'est pas obligatoire on se voit que le
gouvernement continue donc à mettre la
pression pour la vaccination ils tentent
toutes les incitations par exemple les
détenteurs de faux parce qu'ils
souhaiteraient se faire vacciner peuvent
aller en centre pour le faire et dans ce
cas là ils se feront annuler leurs
documents frauduleux sans encourir de
poursuites je rappelle qu'à la fin de
l'année il y avait 192 mille faux passe
en circulation et katia est ce que la
situation sanitaire s'améliore
oui en effet il ya moins de mal à duke
au vide en réanimation alors je vais
donner des chiffres 1 30 et 1 1532
patients atteints du coc vide hier
contre 31 1621 dimanche contre 33 1447
il y a une semaine un en réanimation le
nombre de nouvelles admissions et
pourtant en hausse il y en avait et plus
de 2000 hier alors qu'il n'y en avait
que sept cents la veille le fait qu'il y
ait moins de personnes en réanimation
évidemment est dû au fait que le variant
omicron provoque moins de formes graves
que le variant delta mais la bonne
nouvelle évidemment qu'on doit retenir
c'est que la cinquième vague des croix
c'est très net en 24 heures il ya eu 26
1464 quoi 475 cas positifs ont été
observés contre 86 1562 dimanche ça fait
beaucoup de chiffres pardonnez moi en
tout cas c'est très net 1 que la
cinquième vague semble en décrue en tout
cas même si traditionnellement le lundi
les chiffres sont moins élevées tout ça
paraît de bonne augure merci beaucoup
katia et je vous renvoie à notre site
internet pour découvrir notre excellent
article sur les situations un peu
inextricable pour justement ces cinq
millions de français qui se voit annulé
leur pass vaccinale ce matin merci katia